pete davidson has been on my show a
whole bunch of times i love pete
yeah that's my dog i love pete and i
heard you guys were close
and i heard you did something really
great for him like when pete was in
trouble needed rehab
you got him a bed at a rehab facility in
malibu i know that went a long way with
them i don't have any siblings you know
so you when you see someone like pete
like that's like a my my little brother
you know he's like my best friend too
but also like a little brother so it's
kind of like you have the opportunity to
live that dynamic of like having a
sibling
because i was the only child so
obviously to me that's like the dream
you know
having a brother or sister or something
like that so pete pete's like that for
me
pete wilden out right that the tv show
yep a long time ago and then and then we
ended up meeting each other
for the dirt the molly crew movie that
we both were in
and then i remember we went out for a
night on new orleans together he was the
only other person that smoked weed
on the cast and so we like we were we
bonded over that at first
and like he just was like this dude's
out of his
goddamn mind so he's got big
dick energy you know he told me that he
told me
i was i was i was around for the whole
creation of that that
that was an interesting time we were it
was like i'll never forget because i was
kind of when i was crashing at
their apartment in new york when they
were when they were together and
it was like something happened i forgot
what like maybe that turn came out or
went viral and we like would step on the
streets and everyone would be like
we were all like yeah we're all like why
is everyone looking at all so
funny man were you shocked like [ __ ] i
mean i've known pete all of a sudden
he's now like america's sex symbol
i remember when like the ari thing
happened like
i just looked at pete and we were all
just like man like the
the average american dude is very proud
absolutely
he just was like a symbol of hope
because he was just like one of the dude
he's one of the one of the boys you know
what i mean just like one of the guys in
the basement
you're gonna get married i think that's
my prediction you're gonna marry megan
i think this is gonna happen and i think
pete's gonna be your best man am i
correct
well that's cool yeah down with that
don't let that big dick energy around
your girlfriend
you listen to me i'm serious it's not
something i'm worried about